alors moi le prénom ilona ça m'évoque
une fille un peu comme moi blonde les
cheveux ondulés les yeux clairs tu sais
pas quoi dire un peuple ondes avec les
cheveux longs et les postulants peuvent
vacances et je peux
les wallons une blonde grande grande
blonde aux yeux bleus pour gaspard du
coup je dirais belle coupe de cheveux
cheveux assez foncé chez les humains
auront peut-être grand brun un peu
coiffé décoiffé un blanc
on a beaucoup de stéréotypes sur les
prénoms alors je me suis demandé ce que
notre prénom on disait de nous et c'est
conditionné notre avenir j'ai rencontré
alors scellier elle est psychologue
sociale et cognitive et a accepté de
répondre à mes questions on encore d'un
visage en moins de 40 minutes secondes
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'en
moins de 40 min seconde on a tout un
ensemble de jugement qui se fout de
façon quasi automatique
je vous assure qu'on entretient dans
gauche ressembler à son prénom ça va
vous faire gagner beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et ne pas y ressemble
et sarah tout au long de l'entretien
mettre les gens dans un état de
je-ne-sais-quoi de mallettes
pour le prochain entretien je vous
laisse rencontré andrea qui sera votre
responsable
bonjour alors comment cela se passe bien
commencé facile d'entretien
excusez moi je coupe mais j'attends
quelqu'un
c'est moi on
attend les mêmes chances selon le prénom
bien évidemment que non encore une fois
pour des raisons sociologiques
par exemple le sociologue baptiste coup
a montré que certains prénoms sont
corrélés alors c'est pas un phénomène de
cause à effet corrélation entre certains
prénoms et les mention très bien au bac
on observe que les constances
aujourd'hui ont davantage mention très
bien au bac que les tidianes voilà comme
on peut bien le voir tout cela est
confondant dieu est pétri de tad de
variables confondante tels que le statut
socio économiques etc et puis c'est pas
parce que constance à virbac aujourd'hui
quant à présent votre bébé constance mon
prochain dans 20 ans ce sera encore le
cas historiquement les prénoms qui
circulait au niveau national étaient des
prénoms qui naissaient dans les classe
aristocratique et qui descendait et puis
qui disparaissait et puis d'autres
prénoms été adopté par la classe
aristocratique d'endosser dix ans mais
aujourd'hui ça a légèrement changé
puisqu'on a des prénoms qui naissent
dans des classes populaires et en
revanche n'ont pas et qui reste et donc
par exemple l'exemple du prénom kevin
qui est très efficace et socialement
france mais c'est exactement le cas de
ces son histoire kevin le mec qui
volettent et goûter aux primaires et qui
portaient des chemises dragon
aujourd'hui il écrit durable dans sa
chambre en pensant devenir le futur
eminem
est ce qu'on ressemble à leur prénom
devenir
psychologique alors peut-être que mina
qu'il existe une personnalité domine
avec vous et ressembler mais les
scientifiques ne l'ont pas encore trouvé
donc non il est hors de question en 2022
au moins de dire qu'il y ait une
personnalité de mina où est souvent on
me pose la question parce
qu'effectivement en astrologie on a
tendance à avoir il ya des sites qui
vous qui vont vous dire qui et mina en
psychologie en sciences nous ne sommes
pas du tout là en revanche mon body
qu'effectivement mina un masque un
costume mina on s'habille en a commencé
bien alors pour être encore une fois à
la hauteur de notre prénom de la tente
des autres et afin de glisser plus
facilement au niveau social jade la meuf
populaire alors qu'elle un prénom de
cailloux elle a beau répéter que c'est
pas une fille facile
six mois et elle se croit mannequin
parce qu'elle a fait trois photos dans
un champ de marguerite s'il ya des
parents qui veulent donner un peu
original différencions à leurs enfants
par exemple fanny avec un n ca permet à
l'enfant de différencier ou finalement
savoir 10 rebonds alors sur
l'orthographe non conventionnelles c'est
très clair c'est handicapant nous savons
pertinemment qu'il est
épuisant pour quelqu'un de devoir se
corriger systématiquement lorsqu'il
rencontre famille en disant ah mais
c'est fanny mais ces familles avec un
seul n et fanny d'ailleurs pas passer sa
vie a expliqué que ces familles avec un
soleil mais vaut mieux un prénom
original fait de toutes pièces nouveau
qu'on n'a jamais entendu qu'un prêt non
conventionnelles avec une orthographe
non conventionnelles finalement ce
serait quoi le prénom idéal
le prénom idéal je n'ai pas la réponse à
cette question il faut que ce soit très
simple à penser donc les prénoms que
vous adorez pour des raisons historiques
ou parce que une histoire complètement
dingue derrière c'est formidable mais
une fois que votre enfant va se balader
avec à longueur d'existence et donc il
faut un prénom simple est d'ailleurs une
certaine sagesse impopulaire puisque
l'on voit très clairement aujourd'hui
que les prénoms se raccourcissent
qu'elles sont très claires c'est souvent
delléa minard nani qui sont des prénoms
qui vont être assimilable par à peu près
toutes les cultures
et donc il ya cette intelligence des
parents qu'ils comprennent bien que
c'est pas où son enfant va vivre de plus
en plus on vit à l'étranger et serra est
donc un prénom simple s'il vous plaît
faites simple